queremos saber cuántos tiburones se
vieron en el campamento y lo que tenemos
aquí es una gráfica de imágenes gráfica
de imágenes y la razón por la que es
llamada gráfica de imágenes es porque
usa imágenes usa imágenes para darnos
información en este caso usa la imagen
de un tiburón y nos dice que que una de
estas imágenes es igual a un tiburón
entonces una de estas imágenes es igual
a un tiburón así que qué nos dice esta
gráfica de imágenes que nos dice aquí
aquí se nos está indicando cuántos
tiburones vieron cada día vieron
tiburones el lunes el martes el
miércoles y el jueves
cada una de estas pilas nos indica
cuántos tiburones vieron cada uno de
esos días entonces por ejemplo cuántos
tiburones vieron el lunes aquí se nos
indica cada
es un tiburón que vieron el lunes vieron
122 tiburones vieron el lunes entonces
el lunes vieron dos tiburones así que lo
voy a poner de este lado dos tiburones
vieron el lunes
ahora vamos con el martes aquí hacemos
lo mismo queremos saber cuántos
tiburones vieron el martes el martes
vieron 12 tiburones entonces el martes
vieron 2 tiburones así que 2 tiburones
ahora vamos con el miércoles el
miércoles cuantos tiburones dieron cada
tiburón recuerda representa un tiburón
que vieron entonces el miércoles vieron
123 tiburones tres tiburones
entonces el miércoles vieron tres
tiburones
y por último el jueves el jueves cuántos
tiburones vieron 1 2 3 4 tiburones
entonces el jueves vieron cuatro
tiburones
entonces cuántos tiburones en total
vieron en el campamento vamos a sumar
todo lo que hemos contado entonces vamos
a sumar todos estos números dos más dos
es 443 es 7 y 7 4 es 11 entonces en
total vieron 11 tiburones entonces bueno
nuevamente una gráfica de imágenes es
una es una manera de mostrar información
aquí se nos dice cuántos tiburones
vieron cada día si queremos saber
cuántos tiburones vieron el martes
entonces contamos 12 el martes vieron
dos tiburones si queremos saber cuántos
tiburones vieron el jueves contamos 1 2
3 4 4 tiburones fueron los tiburones que
vieron el jueves y si queremos saber el
total de tiburones que vieron durante el
campamento contamos contamos 2 más 2 más
34 dos más dos es 4 4 13 7
74 es 11 11 tiburones fueron el total de
tiburones que vieron durante el
campamento y terminamos